two days on and what unfolded in this
nightclub is only just sinking in
friends of Cody came in the pouring rain
to lay flowers struggling to process
what's happened to
devastated
um just the impact it's had on myself
family friends I mean obviously me and
Kelsey are part of a friendship Group
which has a hole now that can't be
filled
um I was out the night it happened
and it hit me like a ton of bricks like
I said he just had an infectious smile
A Love For Life his friends his football
his family and he just tragic just
horrendous really really horrible and uh
just I know for me it's it's that I
can't get scripture at the minute anyone
that knew him wouldn't say a bad word
about him that's the thing he's just
wrong place wrong time and you cut like
it's not nice it just hasn't hit yet
forensic investigation continues at the
crane nightclub but there has been
progress a 22 year old man from
Birmingham was arrested just after
midnight in London a 21 year old man
also taken into custody both now being
questioned on suspicion of murdering
Cody Fisher the 23 year old Stratford
Town player was on the dance floor with
friends when he was approached by a
group and stabbed police say they have
already been sent a number of images and
witness accounts from those who were
inside the club two nights ago but the
appeal for information including phone
footage continues to be made
in a statement dcie Ian Ingram from West
Midlands police said it's vital that we
hear from everybody who saw any part of
what happened that night no matter how
insignificant they think it might be
Cody's family and friends are devastated
by what happened and we'll continue to
work to bring them answers
the Cody's teammates there is a sense of
shock
it wasn't
you know like I said before I think
everyone's just completely speechless at
the moment
um
and it's hard to put into words really
close friend Jess Chatwin pictured here
with Cody paid tribute on social media
my poor baby she said I'm so sorry this
has happened to you
it is clear Cody Fisher was loved by
many how and why he became the victim of
a fatal knife attack while celebrating
Christmas is still unknown Dan Whitehead
Sky News in Birmingham